The Season 5 finale of Arrow brought back
a bunch of fan favourite characters for an
epic showdown on Lian Yu and culminated in
an explosive cliffhanger.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I want to take a look at
that Season 5 cliffhanger ending and see if
we can figure out who survived and who's returning
for Season 6.
A quick reminder that my Arrowverse giveaway
is still running, so, for a chance to win
any of these Arrow, Flash or Supergirl Funko
Pops, subscribe and leave a comment with your
thoughts on the finale or Season 6.
And just be aware that, obviously, there are
spoilers ahead if you're not up-to-date yet
with Arrow.
So, this season Prometheus was certainly the
villain we've been looking for on Arrow, always
ten steps ahead of Oliver.
I really enjoyed Josh Segarra's performance
and his character was so irredeemably bad
that he even killed himself at the end hoping
to destroy Oliver's life by setting off the
bombs on Lian Yu to kill almost everyone that
Ollie cared about.
As shocking as this was, this is, of course,
a comic book show and unless we see bodies
dead and buried, and even sometimes then,
it's hard to believe that they are all really
dead.
On top of that, various characters that were
on the island at the end have already been
confirmed for Season 6 by the showrunners,
so let's examine who probably made it and
how they survived.
Actress Katie Cassidy has already been confirmed
to return as Black Siren for Season 6 and,
given she was working with Prometheus, it's
quite likely she was aware of the bombs that
he'd set on the island, so she probably had
a means of getting off the island already
arranged.
As Black Siren is coming back as a regular
next season, I wonder whether she could even
get a main villain role, if not for the whole
season, then perhaps at least initially?
And actors Juliana Harkavy and Rick Gonzalez
who play Dinah and Rene are also confirmed
as returning for Season 6.
In the finale, we finally see Dinah validated
as the new Black Canary by Quentin Lance,
which is nice because Dinah was the original
Black Canary in the comics before Laurel Lance
took on the mantle.
But how did she, Wild Dog and the others survive
all those bombs?
Remember, Oliver says to Felicity there's
an Argus supply ship on the Eastern side of
the island, but that appears to be just minutes
before the bombs go off, so it seems unlikely
they could have made it there in time.
However, let's not forget that Slade Wilson
is with them, and he knows Lian Yu well and
has just spent many years locked up in a reinforced
supermax prison on the island.
So, I suspect Slade probably took as many
of them as he could to the safety of the Argus
prison bunker.
Speaking of Deathstroke, given that in the
finale Oliver gives Slade Wilson a file with
information on his son Joe, it seems unlikely
that the show would open up this thread without
exploring it further down the road, which
suggests that there are possible storylines
ahead about Slade looking for his son.
Now, Manu Bennett is currently busy with other
roles, so whether he will return or how much
he could return for Season 6 is still unsure.
Deathstroke was a great character when he
was a regular on the show and with the finale
cameo of Oliver's mother Moira, who Slade
killed in Season 2, it would be amazing to
see Deathstroke return and further redeem
himself next season.
Felicity, Diggle, Thea, Curtis, Quentin and
Nyssa were also with Slade, Dinah and Rene
at the end, and obviously it wouldn't be a
good move for the show to kill off these main
characters in between seasons.
I suspect most of them made it to safety with
Slade, but there's always a chance we get
to see a few of them picked off in the opening
episode of season 6.
For example, Thea has had a lot less to do
this season, so you could argue that she'd
be the most obvious one to go, however, I
feel she won't be killed off on the island,
especially as Merlyn may have given his life
to save hers.
But could the show pull a similar move to
what The Flash did this season with HR and
Tracy, in other words, did they rekindle the
romance between Felicity and Oliver as a way
to raise the stakes for her character before
possibly killing her off?
After all, Prometheus did say to Oliver, 'it's
gonna be lonely without mom and Felicity',
just before he blew up the island.
Or, given the fact that there's little audience
attachment to the character, maybe it will
be Samantha, the mother of Oliver's son, William,
who doesn't make it off Lian Yu.
A couple of baddies whose fate is less certain
would be Evelyn and Talia.
Evelyn was last seen still locked up in the
cage and Talia had been knocked out by Nyssa.
Though you can never totally count out a character
who's got the name al-Ghul!
Now, let's not forget about another teased-but-not-seen
death during the finale: Malcolm Merlyn.
Merlyn took Thea's place after she stepped
on a landmine and sent her away with the others
after Digger Harkness, aka Captain Boomerang,
and his gang caught up with them.
Thea then saw an explosion in the distance
and assumed Merlyn had died, but remember
Slade Wilson's words to Boomerang earlier
in the episode: "Assumption is the mother
of all failures".
However, John Barrowman, who plays Merlyn,
made a Facebook video shortly after the episode
finished, saying that he won't be back for
Season 6 and that he's very sad to be leaving
the Arrowverse.
So, it looks like this is the end for Merlyn
then, but at least he was able to redeem himself
somewhat by sacrificing himself for his daughter.
Of course, we're still in comic book territory
here so it's possible that the showrunners
decided to have Merlyn's death off-screen
to leave things more open for the future.
After all, Merlyn was looking pretty cocky
when Boomerang turned up and it's not unfeasible
that he could have pulled Boomerang onto the
landmine while launching himself as far away
as he could from the explosion.
And let's not forget this green vial that
he wears around his neck.
If that contains waters from the Lazarus Pit,
then he could use it to heal any major injuries
from the blast.
Malcolm has returned from apparent death before
and has dubbed himself the Magician both in
the TV show and the comics so, even if he
did die, we can't absolutely rule out his
return, even if it's only in flashbacks.
So, who do you think survived Lian Yu and
what did you think about the Arrow season
finale?
Also, what would you like to see happen in
Season 6?
Don't forget to comment and subscribe to enter
my Arrowverse Funko Pop giveaway.
And if you enjoyed this, do please leave a
like and while you're here check out my Flash,
Supergirl and other DC TV and movie videos
by tapping or clicking the links here.
Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!